got a couple of questions that you can
see we're going to work through today
i've only i put them both here not
because i want you to do both of them
right now
but because i thought oh if you're going
to take a screenshot of the um
of what's up on screen right now i might
as well just let you do it all in one
hit rather than do it twice
uh so there the top question i'd love
you to have a start
at and it's our warm-up and then we will
send you into breakouts for the second
question the first one i think is
sufficiently short and straightforward
that you won't need that
so go ahead take your screenshot so
you've got it there
and accessible because this won't be
there forever
and then um haven't got the first one
and i'd highly advise you
to make sure you draw a really decent
diagram
of reasonable size please use a ruler
um and we will be able to have a go at
that together in the next
few minutes as everyone else arrives so
top question that's your warm-up
secondary question you can see that's
got a bit more um
it's got a bit more it has a few more
legs to it so we will do those um
together once we send you into breakouts
but have a go
i hope you have at least got a decent
version of this diagram drawn
in your own book it is just essential if
you couldn't tell already
we had a look at nature of proof type
questions as part of our
review for the trials and for the hsa
last lesson
and today i want us to focus on um
reasoning in three dimensions obviously
that comes under 3d vectors
even though for these particular
questions well for this one at least
there's not a sophisticated amount of
vector thinking
involved the second question we're going
to do this morning is another um story
but that's why i gave this to you as the
warm up
okay now what we are trying to find here
what's the what's the question
um what we are after is we want to
understand what is the angle
between this triangle abc
i guess you could call it the slanty one
because all of the other faces that make
up this
tetrahedron are all on the coordinate
planes i was about to say axes that's
sneaky isn't it so
you've got those orthogonal faces not
signed
but then you've got this abc here which
is uh kind of facing
us at an angle and it's it's oblique as
it were
and we want to find the angle between
that and the x
y plane the base as was described in the
question
right so being that we've got a couple
of different
uh ways in which this thing is off at a
funny angle we need to find some lengths
and at the moment all we really know is
that you've got this
from the origin to a and then from the
origin to b
and the origin to c and we've been told
those are
equal sides right and i believe the
length that was given to us was t
okay so i'm going to use that as kind of
my starting point for example
if you think about this length which is
t and
i made that unintentionally fat sorry
this length which is also t
because we have these coordinate axes
now there's the
z-axis going upwards and the y-axis
going out to the right
um we know those are at right angles so
we've got a right-angled triangle here
right even though it doesn't look like
it so that tells us we've got
some lengths that we can take advantage
of so i would say
um i'm going to use this purple in here
that this length this hypotenuse here
this triangle is the isosceles right
angle triangle right so you've got a 1
1 root 2 relationship so therefore being
that it's not one and one it's t
and t i can say this is root two times t
and i'm happy to just state that as i'm
trying to sort of paddle my way through
the question
right now the reason why that's
important is because that's off at an
angle and it's going to help me
understand triangle abc
it's not the only thing that i need
though i'm also going to need to work
with
this a b length over here you can see
this one
is going to form another side of this
oblique part here
thankfully i already know what a b is
being that
o a and o b and o c are all equal to one
another
if i've got b c being root two times t
then i've also got a b being the same
now i'm just going to write that a b
and that distance out here
root 2 times t because in fact that's
not going to be the part that's going to
be useful to me i don't need the whole
length
i want to be able to bisect that because
that will help me get the angle that i
need
so you can see if i bisect that let's
find the midpoint right there
and i'm going to connect it to that bc
length that i had before you can see i'm
trying to form
more right angle triangles here so i can
get the angles that i need
that's going to be half of a v right so
root 2 on 2 times t last i checked
root 2 on 2 was just another way of
saying 1
on root 2. so that's that length
in there where are we going to go next
well i can see
sort of uh inside here let me use i've
got another color
here let me use orange to indicate that
so you can see that length there i can
find by
pythagoras right i've been doing this
all the way through because i have a
right angle triangle here
i use the same knowledge to get a b
where's the right angle triangle hiding
in here
which plane is it on can you go ahead
and tell me in the chat
what plane is this new right angle
triangle
um oh i'll call this m since it was a
midpoint
omb what plane is that on can you see it
okay thank you angered was in first
though i assume a bunch of you were also
just
looking and maybe typing as well yes
it's it's flat on the xy plane
so therefore you can see i think i will
have enough
use of colors here you can see if i zoom
in a little bit
right there is the right angle okay so
i've got
this side here one on root two t i've
got this side here which is t
that's the hypotenuse so therefore i can
use that to infer
this length over here now you can think
about this
carefully right you can see it's not
only right angled but it's also going to
be
uh isosceles can you see why it's going
to be isosceles um
being that you've got this uh sort of
isosceles triangle here
and you've gone to the midpoint and
you've got this 45 degree angle here
plus a 90. so therefore let's see i'm
going to
mark them in here these two angles in
here are both going to be 45
so in fact even though i've got this um
i could use pythagoras to find it in
this right angle triangle
i can use the same sort of
proportionality trick you've not just
got right angle triangles you've got
similar triangles flying around
everywhere right
so this this triangle here is the same
one one root two triangle
right so therefore this is one and this
is one like one to one
not the length one but ratio one to one
and it's going to give you the same
length
that you got over here so i'm going to
get
one on root two t up and down
from o to m as well now from here there
is
one last right angle triangle that's um
that we could use if you wanted to try
and find out
uh you know this angle in here um you
could
see it's it's kind of thin so it's hard
to pick it out i'm going to need one
more color here
here we go
hardly looks like a right angle triangle
there but that's of course because it's
off
at an angle it's offered a couple of
different angles right
so you can use this triangle you've
already got
let's see here this length here and this
length here so that's going to be
opposite and adjacent so that's going to
give you
10 right so therefore you could say all
right i can say
tan of and i'm going to name this angle
here it's kind of
stuck here in the corner right what
color would be most
appropriate i think i should go back to
green
it's this angle here and it's kind of
standing up
and it's facing towards the z-axis
from m looking at the z-axis so
therefore
the angle's name would be whoopsie daisy
went back to green
it looks like it's going to be o and
then
m and then c it's going to be opposite
on adjacent right so it's going to be
the opposite side is t
and the adjacent side is going to be one
on root two
t so i've got one on root two
t like so so i'm going to have
tan of o m c being
uh have a look here my t's will cancel
i've got one over 1 on root 2 so that
looks to me like
root 2 and if you go ahead and pop in
tan inverse of root 2 what do you find
what do you get
you want to go ahead and post in the
chat what they've already rounded
yeah fantastic thank you veren emmanuel
also got in there um
i should put an approximately equal sign
shouldn't i approximately equals
55 degrees so that's kind of nice
and you can see the reason that we went
through there if the question was
as the original question was actually i
just slightly adapted it if the question
was to prove
for instance that it was roughly equal
to 55 or
an equal result that you might have been
asked to prove is that
that angle i'll just call it theta
is equal to tan inverse of root two
or you might even ask to prove that it
was cos inverse
of one on root three you'd need the
hypotenuse in there the one that i drew
here in orange and we would need to
provide that reasoning a little more
clearly
i haven't provided you i haven't told
you rather how many marks would be
assigned to this
but you might see something like two or
three marks that would have to be
attached to the reasoning
that we would have to say things like
okay this is a right angle triangle
why is that omb is a right angle
triangle
why is that how do i know that it's
going to be isosceles and things like
that are really important to reason
through but
i wanted you to just get your mind
warmed up again as i said before